the reason why we have a much better
handle on crime now is because we have
trained the police to be police not
social workers it's not their job not
educators it's not their job to a degree
not even role models they have to be
like sergeant Joe Friday out there they
don't have time to sit down and have a
cup of coffee and nosh on what's taking
place because we have turned the police
department into a reactive agency
they're not proactive so they're racing
around going from 1 911 911 now that's
not the kind of policing I like but
that's just the way it is so if the cops
are going to be responsive they can't
always sit down and try to figure out
who's right who's wrong so their job is
like everyone up take them into the
hoosegow the cop shop and a judge figure
it out at arraignment who should be
released who should be incarcerated who
should be given bail who should be
remanded to jail that's good policing
when you have limited resource and what
the recessionary times we're in and no
longer any stimulus money to keep cops
on the payroll with less cops and
enables you to do more so I think that's
why at this point was still able to keep
the crime down significantly in a time
of recession but we can only hold out
for so much time as we have less and
less police and more and more people
taking advantage of the criminal
opportunities that are before them
absolutely the better educated you are
it just means you have an opportunity to
become a more well-heeled criminal man
white-collar criminal with a number two
pencil and rip off everybody by going to
Wall Street where the banks are too big
to fail and then we bail you out so
instead of doing triple life without
parole for sticking a gun in somebody's
back in Robin over $25 you rob them for
25 million dollars but you know
something at least you can read The Wall
Street Journal right isn't that an
advantage in life now in reality it's
the basic ability to take care of
yourself and for those that you have
responsibility so so learning what life
is about now nowadays the pension is to
have you earn an academic diploma most
people that I have ever met including
myself because I don't have a diploma I
got kicked out of high school I'm not
going to qualify for an academic
deployment they're not going to go on to
college they're not going to get a BS or
whatever that is or in fact magna
laude because some of them are going to
major in having a 44 magnum in their
hand so they need to be taught skills
it's called technical high school it's
called in middle school finding out if
their adaptability is in the academic
world or it's that their thoracic and
that they like to work with their hands
and they'd like to learn a trade and
then giving them the opportunity to do
what it is that they desire to do even
charter schools nowadays is what folks
charter schools is the answer you know
it's more focused it's more discipline
it gives the child a better opportunity
in the belly of the beast there's not
one charter school in America that's
devoted to teaching technical skills so
is everybody going to be a white collar
workers everybody going to be a go to
Wall Street and become a thief and a
financial institution or a bank and then
tell us how they should reward
themselves with a bonus because they
worked so hard robbing us morning noon
and night with derivatives and subprime
mortgages and giving out loans to people
have no income no jobs no credit I know
that's wrong you know that song but hey
they're smarter than us they're brighter
than us they went to Harvard they went
to ya then went to the London School of
Economics they went to war in the
business school Oh fart all of them send
them the Gitmo lock them up that's right
since
clearing them out of terrorists al-qaeda
nut Nick's right and tally manwani
please when we put all the white-collar
criminals over there and get mo